[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que damos la palabra a
artistas gente de las ciencias de las
artes políticos diplomáticos y claro
está de la sociedad civil cerca de 4000
satélites de todo tipo nos observan en
permanencia y esa cifra deberá crecer
exponencialmente en los años a venir
vivimos acá solo que ya algunos llaman
la nueva conquista del espacio para
hablarnos de ellos contamos aquí en
nuestros estudios con la presencia de
olivia y ex presidente de la empresa
francesa prometeo creada en 2020 y que
se dedica precisamente a la fabricación
de mini satélites o nano satélites hoy
de pierce bienvenido a esta escala en
parís gracias como yo un gusto tenerlo
con nosotros hoy es ustedes dicen querer
ayudar a los países de américa latina y
de áfrica notablemente prometeo como
empresa a avanzar en la soberanía y en
la resiliencia en términos del dominio
del espacio qué quiere decir esto
completamente pero tras dos nociones de
evidencia y subvención muy importante
para prometer
riesgos enormes y es muy importante
encontrar soluciones para las extracción
del carbón por ejemplo hay reserva muy
importante océanos
ríos mares y bosques y con cola rígida
bosques esos acciones no se hace con don
o con bicicleta es un lado el otro lado
son
oleoductos gasoductos
la economía depende de la energía y de
la información y de nuevo tener un
monitoring de de las fuentes de energía
y de las fuentes de información cableado
submarino si no están bien son
distancias muy largas de kilómetros si
él necesita satélites para tener un
control del local de la vida local con
una visión global es esto lo que ustedes
llaman también llegó inteligencia
ustedes hablan también de el new space
nuevo espacio son términos que para el
público es difícil entender qué es esto
de la geo inteligencia qué es esto del
new space
a vivir el espacio a new player a nuevos
jugadores es el resultado de la
miniaturización de la tecnología de la
hibridación del digital de la bajada del
costo del kilo y norbit que hoy día no
es solamente empresa muy grande muy
importante que puede trabajar y fabricar
soluciones en el espacio o libia pero
decíamos su empresa prometeo fue creada
en 2020 hace poco tiempo naturales
naturalmente cuando estará en operación
el primer mini satélite que ustedes
están pensando elaborar y cuáles son las
características que puede aportarle a un
país a una sociedad que se interese
eventualmente en adquirir a futuro en
los años creo que es en 2023 2024 a más
tardar que quiera adquirir un mini
satélite de prometeo pero es un que deja
usted tiene gas son una carrera
anunciamos hace dos semanas que el
primer satélite va a volar en octubre de
2023 va a tener la primera constelación
en 2025 y la idea es tener la primera
constelación es muy importante de
observación de la tierra porque promete
es para observar la tierra si entiendo
bien tenemos entonces mini satélites
como los que ustedes piensan elaborar
que es para observación de la tierra si
llega una tempestad si hay una
inundación si hay una sequía tenemos
evidentemente satélites de tipo militar
tenemos grandes satélites de
telecomunicaciones
yo decía hay actualmente cuatro mil más
o menos cuatro mil satélites ya en
órbita hay empresas que estiman varias
empresas que tienen todo un programa
para lanzar más y más satélites en los
años a venir hablábamos de lo que es una
nueva conquista del espacio quien regula
todo esto porque parece que vamos a una
situación donde el que tenga más dinero
podrá llegar más rápido y dominar al
resto una especie de conquista del
espacio un poco salvaje
y hay una idea importante que él comete
con el mito de cometer llevar el frío
griego que se lleva para salir de la
gota estabilización y esta
democratización lo que es eso es lo
encadenó
efe exactamente creo que es muy
importante
esta idea de
democratización porque antes llegado una
minoría que controla el espacio con el
'news vez es
mucho más es una democratización al
nivel de la infraestructura y después
vamos a llegar utilizadores es mandar
los datos de observación espacial en el
teléfono un teléfono de cada persona un
poco la revolución con internet que fue
hecha en los años 90 queremos hacer esta
revolución con la observación la llega
ahora hay muchas satélites muchos muchos
satélites de espada el aula la
comunicación la observación de la tierra
es hoy día un nuevo desafío sobre la
regulación
comunicación y regulación sobre las
frecuencias
sobre la observación la ster hay mucho
menos regulación y con esta
democratización mucho más gente puede
mandar salir satélites en el espacio y
cuando es una revolución en él
el ambiental
es muy importante tener la capacidad ser
responsable de usar satélites y después
hoy anidada que el satélite es al fin de
su vida la regresar a quitar el espacio
pero esto es posible garantizar hoy en
día quiero decir con esto wang web que
es esta empresa estadounidense dice que
va a lanzar satélites en los próximos
años 2400 en los próximos tres años
samsung ha dicho que va a lanzar cuatro
mil son más que 12.000 o en 2000 o sea
estamos de 4000 vamos a pasar a 25.000
30.000 hay la garantía de que las
grandes empresas de que los estados
china rusia eeuu o la propia unión
europea digan este satélite ya no
funciona lo bajo con todas las reglas de
vidas sin causar riesgos
es una cuestión general con
con la lucha con la contaminación con
todo es una cuestión de responsabilidad
nacional o continental infancia hay la
ley nacional espacial es el único país
que va en línea de ser responsable
europa hay una visión también china no
sé tal vez hay siempre un riesgo es el
que dice el principio de que es ley la
que dice que es una decisión final
horrible que a un momento si hay
demasiado satélite exactamente un día va
a tener un accidente global y que va a
haber pedazos y que la consecuencia será
que todo el espacio será cerrado lo que
es muy importante si queremos hablar
para mejorar la situación ambiental en
el mundo con un sistema de chequear que
se estima que no vamos vamos
con contaminar el espacio es muy
importante pero por ejemplo hay de
astrónomos hoy en día que dicen que con
los 4000 satélites que existen ya hoy en
día en órbita empiezan a tener problemas
para la observación de lo que es la vía
láctea por la luz que éstos emiten no
tendrá efectos en los animales en la
naturaleza tanto satélites tantos miles
y miles de luces con los rayos que todo
esto implica
seguramente en los siglos 17 con el
acabó después con la intención de la
electricidad hay astronómicas que dicen
que la electricidad no servía es un
fracaso claro que la visión es mucho
peor no yo piensa que hay que ser
responsable y que este sistema va a
llegar soluciones para mejorar
globalmente el agua
y contaminación de los suelos
'smart city' basuras etcétera
según congresos a veces es siempre un
head of me lo más importante es
construir con una visión responsable en
este terreno ok es un tema de
responsabilidad
decíamos francia es el único país hoy a
nivel internacional que está
implementando una regulación para los
satélites pero concretamente mi pregunta
sería a futuro ustedes por ejemplo una
vez que pongan sus satélites en órbita
cómo va a pasar esta cuestión de la
soberanía
satelital con un país supongamos que
argentina quiere comprarles a ustedes un
satélite cómo va a pasar cuál será la
relación de autonomía de argentina con
respecto a ustedes de nuevo residencia y
soberanía no residencia es también con
la ocaña tomar decisiones políticas es
muy importante con efectos sobre la
economía es mejor tener sus datos su
análisis para tomar decisión no usar
imagen de china o de américa y en lo que
componemos es con países ofrecer el
sistema completo satélites con sol y
también la estación de para para hacer
función de datos y crear servicios y
todo se va sobre la
responsabilidad y el control total del
país
el país va a tener su soberanía
aquí tomamos el mundo decisiones con
algunas imágenes americanos es
importante que un país para su problema
de base en la parte estratégica o la
parte independiente tener la capacidad
de tener sus datos su control en su país
es la idea y normalmente esta idea
cuesta millones en billones
de juego o de dólares o ya con él nuevas
veces dividimos los costos por un factor
20 y el acceso existe hoy día gracias a
la miniaturización en la bajada de los
precios pero que es importante cuál es
la revolución de cometer es importante
es diferente de las otras soluciones
primero el tiempo queremos hacer la
primera constelación en europa en
observación de la tierra la carrera
segundo vamos a llevar la bici con 30 y
satélite no es más una imagen por día
hagamos de la imagen al comportamiento
con cuando tenemos imagen que ha dado al
cara 30 minutos es posible tener una
visión y entender lo que pasa en un país
una situación es un cambio enorme
después hay la hiper reactividad es la
capacidad de la constelación de
comunicar entre los diferentes satélites
con otras constelaciones
en un tiempo dejar en un pedido y la
respuesta no de 10 hojas de tal vez de
una hoja es cambio en la herramienta
cambia totalmente en el tercer y último
punto es la fusión vamos a utilizar
datos
de la consideración de otro cancelación
datos in situ del internet mezclar para
llevar soluciones de imagen a datos
inteligentes hacer complejo gracias a la
fisión dong ruiz its que no existe
hiperactividad y por fin fusión de datos
e inteligencia -yo inteligencia su
pregunta al suelo y mucha inteligencia
dentro el satélites pues sin duda alguna
es un programa bastante ambicioso es más
que interesante como proyecto de
desarrollo sabiendo que digámoslo de una
europa está llegando bastante tarde a
esto y nosotros estamos llegando también
ya al final de esta emisión o lydia pips
yo le agradezco usted es su presencia
recuerdo que es presidente de prometeo
empresa francesa dedicada a la creación
de los satélites y a ustedes les damos
nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]